All right, folks, welcome back.
All right, so we're looking at the S&P futures contract for June 2022.
On the left-hand side, you can see that we have a daily chart.
And on the right-hand side, it's a one-hour chart.
So I'm only going to do this to save time, also bring your attention to levels that are
sensitive on one time frame, higher time frame, and how it's subordinate on the lower time
frame to those higher time frame levels.
If you don't know what I'm referring to, obviously you'll understand more as we go through.
All right, so this morning I had a short little video that I posted about how we had recently
been in this trading range in here.
And if we were to start to move higher and had displacement to the upside, this could
have been a draw on liquidity.
This is the objective I was looking for near term, if we were to break higher.
We had news this morning and unemployment data, which obviously, you know, given the
state of affairs at present, it's a heavy weight around the neck of the markets.
So we had to move lower.
Prior to the opening at 9.30, I talked about how until we had some kind of displacement,
I wasn't really excited about doing much in the marketplace.
I felt that 40.70 was a nice draw on liquidity, which would be below the draw to equal those.
I posted that obviously before 9.30 a.m., so it gave you a target, okay, or my bias.
So I'm thinking what?
If I'm pointing down here before 9.30, am I suggesting that we're going to go up here
or here or here?
No.
So I'm looking for evidence to support the idea that a run below these relative equal
lows is warranted.
I also stated if we went below those lows, that we would draw into that fair value cap.
Now, with the benefit of hindsight, obviously, when I'm talking to folks that have not been
with me or they watched only post-production or post-market reviews or things like that,
it sounds like hindsight, but I assure you, the folks over there on Twitter, and it's
time and date stamped, I don't delete any tweet, and if it's a typo, it stays, okay?
And in my age and my eyes failing like they are, it's probably going to be a reoccurring
theme over there that I typed something correctly, but I'm not sweeping anything under the rug.
I'm not trying to hide anything from you.
I came out in video, explained that I would be more interested in seeing this level down
in here, and if we did, we would draw into this area here.
Now, that is suggesting several things.
Number one, we're expecting the volatility, or I'm expecting the volatility to be significant
enough to take us below these lows, and if that was to occur, then we're going to draw
all the way down into here, which means what?
We're going to have a small range day on the daily chart or a large range day.
Clearly, a large range day.
So there was a lot of things that I laid in your hands this morning that hopefully give
you hope that these things are predictable.
Obviously, I'm not without imperfections.
Yesterday, I mapped out an idea on Twitter and engaged, and I took a loss.
It was a five-point loss, it was not a significant loss, and in fact, I called a level later
in the afternoon how I could have easily gained that back.
Now, when I say those things, understand the premise.
Okay, why am I saying it?
Am I saying it to beat my chest and sound egotistical?
No.
I wanted everyone to see what it's like, even if I do something wrong, and I don't rush
out there to try to fix it, okay, because that's going to be your initial response to
you taking a losing trade in your demo account, or worst-case scenario, rush into trading
live funds when none of you are ready to do that yet.
Now, I understand there's traders in here that are watching the videos, and you're probably
profitable.
When I say that you shouldn't be trading with live funds, you shouldn't be trading with
live funds with these concepts because you're still learning them, which I'll end this video
with a request from all of you so you guys can let me know in the comments section what
you would like to see going forward.
I have a suggestion, and you guys are open to give me input on that, and you as a community
will let me know what it is that we're going to be doing.
All right, so on the daily chart to the left, you can see we have those relative equal lows
I mentioned.
The draw on liquidity was there, so I was focusing what?
Sell side, or I had a bearish bias.
I gave conditions that if we went below there, it's not going to go down there and go up.
It's going to go down into this area here.
So with those levels transposed over to the hourly chart now, this level here is this
level on the daily chart.
This level down here is this level.
Now obviously, some of you are like, that's pretty obvious, but you'd be surprised how
many new students I have, and they get lost in the time frames.
So whatever you're doing in your higher time frame, you want to start your annotations
there, but keep them simple.
You want to see a level that it's going to draw to, or what key levels that may be a
factor for changing or suggesting a bias is in play.
As I did this morning, I said, I believe we're going to go down below here.
I thought that's likely to occur.
And if that does happen, we're drawing into this area here, not just going below relative
equal lows to go higher.
Because there's a lot of people all around the world that are being exposed to my content,
whether it be directly from me or someone that's learned my concepts and have tried
to create something new with a twist of their own, they're teaching that it's always a
relative equal low or equal lows to hit those and then go the other way.
That's not the case.
Narrative must be understood, and narrative, unfortunately, requires experience, and experience
is what I'm lending you.
So when I'm talking to you or if I'm pointing to something, I'm lending my three decades
of experience doing it.
That way, you can hopefully grow faster, but I'm not trying to rush you along.
But it's easier for a student to be engaged when they're shown something, to anticipate
something, and then they have the benefit and enjoyment of watching it pan out in their
own charts, which I think that's the epiphany that every student under me and I guess anyone
else when they have that moment of astonishment where it delivers as they're expecting or
hoping to see happen, it feels like they're in alignment with the marketplace, which is
many times not the case for retail traders and new traders or long term struggling traders
that are breakeven, they just can't find their footing and can't be profitable.
It's a wonderful feeling and I know once you have that moment, you'll want to dig deeper
and that inspires me as a mentor too.
So if you watch this pan out today and you expected it based on being in the community
and audience members this morning before the market opened up with my commentary, give
me a heads up in the comment section and what was it like to watch it unfold.
So over here on the hourly chart, we had a fair value gap here, swing low, we had displacement,
we consolidated going into midnight last night, New York time, it rallied up, traded into
a fair value gap here and up into the bearish order block.
So we have this order block, it touches it, you can take that trade but I'm trying to
draw your attention to these areas here, where there's three candles, one candle in the middle
that has an exposed area that is not overlapped with the previous candles low, immediate candle
to the right of it.
So there's that little section that we call a fair value gap.
Price goes above it, hits the order block but look at the candles.
See how the candles' bodies stay predominantly in between these two levels here?
So yeah, there's a wick and there's a wick but largely the volume is encapsulated in
between these two levels.
I drew your attention here, I mentioned how we would likely go below those lows and then
we have an old low back here.
So even if you weren't looking at my commentary or watching it, this framework here then running
to that low is something that you should have identified but if you didn't it's okay, you'll
get it in time.
This price or level here is the opening price at midnight in New York local time, so I'm
extending it out in time.
So now think about what I've done so far here, before the fact, in Twitter, in a video and
post I stated that I'm interested in seeing these taken out and I like 470 as an interest.
Okay, that's a draw on liquidity.
So if we're up here and I'm stating that I think 4070 is interesting, your eye should
go to that level and study what it is at that level that may be of interest to me.
So that way it forces you to dig into the chart.
Now in the beginning working with me as your mentor, this is going to be very frustrating
for some of you because unfortunately some of you just want it spelled out for you and
I don't teach that way.
You're not going to learn that way and I'm not going to spoon feed you and you're going
to learn better and more productively by you going in doing the very things that you would
be doing if you didn't need me holding your hand, which means going into the charts, looking
for the evidence and details yourself.
So you had a bearish bias given to you.
You had an objective, a draw on liquidity and in the chart here I'm showing you the
framework for the daily range, the opening price at midnight.
I teach there typically if there's going to be a down day, which is what I was suggesting
before the market opens at 930, we would see a bearish day and look for a draw at the 470.
If that occurs, your attention should be down between these two levels here based on
that daily chart.
Now incorporate power three.
My power three concept is the accumulation of shorts, the manipulation of those individuals
that were already short.
That's what this is here.
That's a Judas swing.
The market goes up to a short term premium, which is high to low, back into a premium
relative to this dealing range high and that dealing range low.
Then the market breaks lower, trades below the short term relative equal lows here,
retraces, consolidates a little bit, breaks once more, consolidates and then attacks the
sell side here and aggressively runs through the 470, which is what we were anticipating
based on my commentary before the market opened and then we take our attention down to here.
So if you are short, you take a partial here, then you wait for the daily range to fulfill.
That means you have to submit yourself to time.
What time?
Three o'clock to four o'clock.
Wait to that last hour of trading because you'll get the delivery of price when it trades
down into that.
All right, now we have the 15 minute time frame on the left hand side and the five minute
chart on the right.
You can see how we rallied up into that fair value gap on the hourly.
We broke down.
Once more traded back above the opening price at midnight here, breaks lower, consolidates.
All of this we'll talk about later in the video.
Then breaks once more, trades up into a fair value gap here, breaks lower and aggressively
runs into that higher time frame daily fair value gap.
On the five minute chart, you can see here we have the equities opening at 930 a.m. here
and I mentioned when we were down here, I said price is initially showing weakness.
It's going lower.
Traders are going to get caught short doing that, chasing price going lower.
They're going to reprice to 4105.
There's buy side liquidity resting there and a fair value gap.
The market immediately after my post runs to that level.
I engaged that with a demo trade.
I entered it and I took profits below that short term low here and then I'll teach you
how I knew this was reversing on me and saved my stop and also took a second partial off.
It rallied up once more, blowing out that short term high.
So we have a lot of chop in the initial opening range, low, higher high than that high, lower
low than that low, lower low again, then rallied through this high and left this fair value
gap.
Consolidated a little bit in here, traded back down in, once more back into the opening
price at midnight, which is this line here.
If you're bearish, you want to be going short at or above that level or as close as you
can get to it.
Like this one here.
Okay.
The market drops down between 11 o'clock and noon.
It consolidates, then retraces back up, takes buy side here, breaks lower, returns back
to a swing low, which we'll talk about in a moment.
Breaks lower again, aggressively runs for that 470 level and it's off to the races down
into the daily fair value gap.
Now if you look at the daily range through the scope of a five minute chart here, you
can see the opening price here at midnight, prices gravitates around that, and in London
they rally and start building in a premium ahead of the 830 time window.
The market creates the high, breaks, takes out short term sell side liquidity here, retraces
back up into, consolidates for the majority of the afternoon, then breaks lower, and then
aggressively attacks the sell side below 470 and then going right back down to that 440
level and then hanging out and consolidating and closing inside that larger daily fair
value gap.
Now I want you to take a look at this price action here.
We're looking at the afternoon.
So with the morning aside, because I've walked everyone through that basically on Twitter
and with the pre-market analysis and commentary, the rules for a afternoon session trade, before
you even consider trading in the afternoon session, you have to consider what is the
daily range trying to do?
Is it trying to expand higher?
Is it trying to expand lower?
Did it reverse in the morning session and is it going to have a counter trend move or
or is it going to just consolidate because it's waiting on a big news event the following
day?
Today we had a big news event.
We had employment data, the market consolidated, and we had a bearish bias.
We were looking for 4070 based on my experience.
I was generous enough to give that to you beforehand with commentary suggesting that
we would trade down into that lower time frame fair value gap on the MASMP's daily chart.
So the framework was one-sided.
It was not ambiguous.
It was specific about what we were looking for.
Once the market started to break after lunch, when does lunch end at 1 o'clock in the afternoon
New York local time?
That is here.
So 12 to 1, there is our New York lunch.
If we're bearish, what did I teach you?
The market will do what?
It will clear the stops during the lunch hour.
What highs were formed in the lunch hour?
Here and prior to it going in, this was the buy side liquidity pool or short term high.
So at 1 o'clock, the algorithm reprices and runs to take the stops above the buy side
here.
So during the lunch hour, we're seeing that it took the stops here.
You can, if you're aggressive, you can put on a trade here because we're in a directional
move.
We're trying to anticipate a large range day and large range days can typically form with
a busy lunch schedule.
And I just recently taught this that the market, if it's going to be a fast market during the
lunch hour, it can create a significant high or significant low.
But the premise mainly is if you're bearish, you're going to be looking for the highs to
be swept because they don't want participants to be profitable that may have assumed a short
position from the morning session or prior to this high forming, they may have already
short here.
And instead of letting the market release and break to lower PV arrays in a discount
market, the algorithm reprices knocks those individuals out because it floods the market
with what?
Buyers at a higher price, higher than what?
Than it was here, than it was here.
So smart money utilizes this run above this short term high as an influx of buying interest
and liquidity that's available immediately while the market is being priced here and
held at that level.
Smart money will go in and sell to those buyers that their orders will be resting above here.
So their stops are being tripped.
Their short position is being knocked out.
And conversely, there's traders that would see that high being broken as a means of getting
long and they have a buy stop that would trigger them getting in on a breakout.
So smart money is cannibalizing those two types of orders.
What orders are they?
Buy side liquidity.
So the counterparty to their short has to have buying interest.
That buying interest is being engineered by the algorithm and it runs up here.
So smart money goes short here with the expectation that they can take off a portion here back
to an old low of 470 and then 440 and then into that fair value gap on the daily chart.
Now, sticking to the rules of the model I'm trying to teach you, if you do not trade during
the lunch hour, that's fine.
You're going to wait until after lunch for I set up the form.
Those of you that have been studying my channel here on YouTube, you understand that this
swing low here to a higher high than that of here is a breaker.
That's my ICT bearish breaker.
What is a breaker?
A breaker is a pattern where price runs out a pool of liquidity, in this case it's a buy
side liquidity pool, and then it reverses and trades back down below that short term
low.
If it trades back up to that and the narrative is bearish, notice that it's not just simply
we have this pattern here and that's all there is.
No, you must know what the market's likely to be reaching for.
If you leave that out, it's not a breaker.
It's a gamble.
It's a guess.
It's a speculation that's aimless.
Notice the difference there?
So this down close candle, the lowest one prior to move up clearing that short term
high and I teach this on the YouTube channel.
So if you've already gone through the 2022 mentorship videos and you're caught up, you're
welcome to go through the other videos as well.
But I'm trying to keep your focus in this series because it's very easy for you to go
into other series on this YouTube channel and get inundated with things and create so
many questions that will feel like they are pertinent to this model and they're not.
Okay, but I'm just giving you a comprehensive view of what it is I look at in price, what
I'm judging, whether or not is it likely to continue going lower and as price starts
to move back up in this level, I would expect and anticipate that level repelling price
and go lower and then be aggressive about trading below that because there's sell side
there.
And then not going below this low here to go higher, we want to see it go through there
and accelerate going down.
It wants to run quickly for that 4070 level because there's larger pool liquidity below
that and then aggressively run into that fair value gap on the daily chart because that's
the imbalance that the algorithm is going to want to reprice to.
In the afternoon, obviously you can see post breaker being traded to.
Heaviness falls below 4070 and then accelerates.
See that?
See how fast it accelerates down?
Small little consolidation, no retracement, no return back to an old low broken support
becomes resistance.
Forget about it.
This is an algorithmic sell day.
Retail doesn't get to do a lot of those retail concepts.
You either are on board beforehand or you watch the ship sail off without you.
And that's basically what you end up seeing here in the price of 440 gets traded through
and back into that daily fair value gap as I mentioned would be the likely target for
today.
All right, so this brings me to the point of the video I promised everyone on Twitter
that I would touch on and I did a little bit of a rant on Saturday, I took my car out for
a spin and you all got to see what it's like to be around ICT where I don't have the benefit
of having the Camtasia studio eddling out because there's a lot of times while I'm making
these videos that things in the house will go on, my kids will interrupt me, my dogs
will come in and bust in the door and you want me to play with them or I'll say something
wrong and get upset about doing something incorrectly while I'm producing the video.
So they're like human traits.
I'm a human being.
I make choices sometimes that aren't the best ones and sometimes, you know, I'm prone to
have chemical imbalances because I'm bipolar and I don't make any excuses for that.
I don't make any attempt to hide it because I know if you spend time with me long enough,
you'll notice it.
So during the rant I gave on the Twitter spaces, I guess it's like a podcast feature to trying
to build up on that platform.
I tested it out this weekend and I mentioned that I would share with you all the model
I'm teaching my son Caleb.
I'm not afraid to teach it to you, I'm not trying to hide it from you, okay, but I wanted
to make sure he had some foundation to what it is he's trying to do and I wanted to spend
time with him and figure out like because of his characteristics, you know, what's his
concerns, what's his fears, what's his comfort level, is he trying to trade the whole daily
range or is he trying to get in and out real quick, small little pieces, that type of personality
inquiry that you have to do as a trader too.
You don't take a model because you see somebody else doing well with it and say I'm going
to do that because if it doesn't match your personality, if it doesn't match the way you
see an engaged price action, you'll never make it work for you, okay.
So I'm aware of that, I'm cognizant of that effect on individuals learning things, not
just this but anything, but with something so technical as this, in this industry, with
as many as we have in terms of variables for choices what to do, you know, think about
all the indicators that are out there, think about all the trading styles and methodologies
and teachers and their respective personalities.
So you have to be able to, number one, be able to put up with them and listen to them
to learn from them and sometimes I'm off putting, I can't retain the attention of everyone and
or they don't like my teaching style or they don't have any faith in me or whatever.
I'm not going to scratch the it's for everyone, but for those that sit down here and they
want to learn from me, obviously you've seen live accounts being utilized this year.
My son started trading in the first week of May of this year, he started trading a
live account and he opened up with AMP futures and I'm not repping them, I'm not saying
anything for you to go and open up an account with them, but I have been asked, are they
a good broker?
I can only report the fact that he has not reported any issues with his fills being executed
and done professionally.
The only issue there was they weren't happy with the fact that I was sharing one of his
statements that he emailed me and they asked him to ask me to take it down, so I took it
down.
But I can talk about the numbers, okay, so here's what he did.
He had an equity low of 28.10 and in a matter of a number of weeks until just at present,
he didn't do any trades today, okay, we were observing, I was teaching, I did trades myself,
but he was observing, he's in the position of spectating, not speculating today, because
I wanted him to understand that the large range day can creep in like it did in the
afternoon and it may not look so clear in the morning, but we were looking at it with
that lens and I was showing that beforehand in the marketplace and in the commentary on
Twitter.
But he's at 18,300 plus, so in the course of like four weeks, that's about 400% return,
in my opinion, that's a remarkable growth that shows obviously he knows what he's looking
for, he knows what he wants to do, he wants to obviously grow his account, he wants to
build it up and not try to hit grand slam home runs.
And because he works at a low paying job, it's real easy to hit that threshold that
he earns on a weekly basis.
So when I sat down with him, one of the things I felt was imperative was he has a very short
attention span, he's easily distracted, so I wanted to give him a model that gave him
a very low threshold for a return of points or pips and since we settled in on the index
futures market for him, it ignores the spread issues that are going to be a plague for traders
that are using Forex.
It's a professional market, it's a very liquid market, the E-mini S&P and it's systematic
in the way it delivers price.
So if I can sit down with him, I want to take into the chart at a specific time of day with
a specific logic in mind and then have him hopefully see a pattern that repeats, it may
not form that day he sits down and then he has to just move to the sidelines and do nothing.
That choice to say I don't see it today and then if something forms after the charts get
closed or if the trader moves away from the charts and they come back later on and they
see it move a certain way, that fear of missing out, you need to squash that quickly in the
beginning and the only way you do that is by backtesting and seeing how many times these
things form.
So while we did that together, because I'm his father and I'm literally next to him,
I'm next to him, giving him my experiences as close as I can possibly be next to doing it.
You know what I mean?
Like I'm sitting here acting like the internal voice for him.
I'm saying, OK, what do you see here?
What do you see there?
What happens if you did this and what happens if you did that?
Where would you think price is going to go?
So I'm literally being the internal dialogue that 30 years of experience would have spoke to him internally.
So he has that inside advantage, OK, that home field advantage, if you will.
He's pushing the buttons, obviously, and if he elects to do nothing based on what I'm asking
about in the chart, sometimes the market moves and he's not in it.
Sometimes he does something and the market does something against him.
And he has that decision of, do I let the stop loss get hit or do I just bail now and figure out
what it is that I did wrong or what I'm uncomfortable about?
So it may not be the ideal learning conditions for everyone, but I know where I'm leading him.
I need him to be prepared to obviously look for a specific element in price action.
And it's algorithmic.
I'm not sitting down with him with anything retail.
I'm not filling his head up with bull flags and bear flags and when they fail,
because I teach my price action students to look for those types of things.
I'm not teaching him trend lines.
I'm not even bringing any of that stuff in.
I'm taking him right to the brass tacks of what it is that the algorithm is going to do
because I only want him to be a one trick pony.
Right now, that's all he needs to be able to feel confident and leave his job.
So I said I would teach it.
I said I would show it to you.
So I'm going to kind of give you the loose framework, you know, what it is that I try to teach him,
what he's looking for, those types of elements.
But before I get into it, I want to remind the viewers,
because this might be the first video you came across with my content.
So I want all of you and to be reminding those of you that have lost this
in the conversation throughout these videos, that price is delivered by an algorithm.
Okay. There is no buying and selling pressure.
That is something that they use as a excuse for what the market does and or doesn't do.
And algorithmic theory is based on time and price.
Now, time and price.
When I wrote this algorithm, coding it leans heavily on the time element.
Okay. What does that mean?
What time of day?
What day of week?
What week of month?
What month of year?
What seasonal influences?
So there's several factors encoded in the algorithm that will seek these reoccurring phenomenon
that can be capitalized on by those individuals that know what it is that they're hunting.
Okay. That little billboard that flashes, hey, it's time for you to engage now.
Okay. That signal, that pattern, that setup, that framework, whatever you want to call it,
the moment right before you push a button, that's what I'm trying to take his attention
into.
Okay. I'm taking all the other distractions away and I want him to go right in and look
at that specific element.
Price levels are useless until time is considered.
Just because it's trading at your favorite price level, this is the reason why support
and resistance is a fallacy.
There's many instances that anyone can go back in hindsight and say, here is where this
line worked and it repelled price up or down.
Do it live consistently.
Pick the right level consistently.
And that's the problem that retail traders have.
I went through that same thing.
I couldn't pick the right support and resistance level, even the higher timeframe ones, because
sometimes you'll have a move where it'll go up, hit a level that would be otherwise viewed
as resistance.
And then it starts to go down and then it goes one more time up higher, higher and then
higher high takes my stop.
And then I'm afraid to go back in and go short, right?
You've all experienced it.
I did the same stuff in the nineties, 1992, 1993, 1994, all those types of fearful events
of getting stopped out and then abandoning my opinion about what I thought the market
was going to do.
Instead of saying, OK, the framework still about I just had the entry wrong.
Let me go back in with less risk this time, less leverage this time and see if it pans
out.
But like most of you and everybody else, those stop out events create fear and anxiety and
uncertainty.
So that's why time has to be considered first, because the algorithm is going to start working
a specific macro.
That means a short order of things that will do as instructions is going to seek a specific
level, move to a premium, move to a discount, suddenly move or consolidate and wait for
another time element in that same trading day or trading week or a month.
OK, so that's the reason why I'm teaching you that that element of time is crucial.
Your inability to know everything that there is to know about time is going to be the area
which you will have the largest growth in, but you'll have the initial adversities.
When when, when, when, when to do this, when to do that, when going through the motions
of what it is I'm teaching you, it'll happen for you that you understand why certain things
are occurring at a specific time.
And I can't articulate it any better than that.
It's just a matter of doing it.
You're sitting with me every week, looking at what I'm trying to share, taking your attention
to a specific price level.
Over time, your eyesight, your understanding, the visibility, the perception of price will
be dialed in.
You'll know what it is I'm doing because you've done it with me for days, weeks and months.
Time is of no use unless price is at a key PD array, OK, just because it's time for you
to be able to sit in front of the charts doesn't mean anything unless it's at a key PD array.
So in other words, blending the two yields astonishing results and the precision that
I share with you.
I've done a plethora of examples proving precision, proving prognostication, forecasting, objectives,
targets, the whole business, OK?
It's not my aim or goal to try to do magic tricks for you, OK?
I don't want to be out here trying to be David Copperfield of the markets and say, here,
watch this sleight of hand and are you amazed by that?
Are you amazed?
My task is I'm making you a wizard, OK?
I'm teaching you the craft.
I'm not up here performing for you.
I try to make it as engaging as I can to keep the attention span on those that are very
limited and bored easily.
I try to get their attention quick with little things that would draw their attention and
hopefully keep them engaged long enough for the effects of learning properly to take root.
So if you look at this price action that's been staring at you, does anything stand out
on this chart?
If you're a new student to price action or if you're a new student to me, a lot of these
things that you're looking at here in terms of the price action, all the movements and
such, it looks like a foreign language you've never learned how to read.
Well if you're looking at price action like this, it looks like it has no reason for doing
what it's doing.
It's completely random.
And one of the fun things I get to experience as a mentor with the insights that I have,
being in a position where I have done a lot of the producing of these things and the authorship
of it, I get the benefit and pleasure of watching people get blown away by the incredible detail
that this algorithm repeats and follows.
If we take all of the noise away from just all this back and forth movement and we add
just a little bit of lipstick, suddenly we have a lot more to work with.
What's the first element to algorithmic theory?
Price or time?
Time.
So time begins in the morning session for us as a index futures trader at 8.30.
That's when a news embargo lifts.
At 8.30 that's when there's usually a news event or some kind of economic report that
comes out at 8.30 New York local time.
So that's the reason why I tell you to set your clocks on your trading view platform
here to the local time in New York.
This candle here is the 8.30 candle in New York time.
This morning I outlined how I felt that we would likely see the market move to a liquidity
pool, a specific liquidity pool, and it would draw down and attack the sell side.
I teach my son to look for setups that are going to target a specific pool of liquidity.
It means I have to have a clear idea where the market's likely to go up for buy side
or down for sell side.
I'm not trading a support resistance idea.
I'm not looking to go to a level to watch it repel away.
That's not what I'm doing.
That's a fallacy.
That's the reason why retail traders drop the ball so many times and or blow their accounts
and never find consistency because they're trying to force something that is designed
to fail.
I don't know why it's so hard for people to acknowledge when they are met with extreme
adversities trying to force retail logic to work.
Can you make money with retail concepts?
Yes.
Yes, you can if you understand how to reprice like I'm teaching it.
If you did those types of things without understanding why the market should do what it's doing,
why is price booking the way it is?
What does that mean?
Why is price going to these specific levels at the time it's doing it?
There's a logic behind that.
And for some that want to say there is no technical science, you know, at some point,
you know, when does it stop becoming useful?
All of it's useful.
Every tiny minute little fluctuation in these price movements are absolutely controlled,
engineered and premeditated.
Either by AI, artificial intelligence, that's the algorithm.
It's following the code that's been written for it.
Or there are times when manual intervention comes in and they will send price to a specific
price level.
Sometimes it's going to be abrupt and aggressive and it may not be fun or pleasurable being
a part of that move.
Other times it will be exhilarating because you were on the right side.
When those moments of intervention occur, that's a manual intervention.
That means someone is literally going in and manipulating price to do a specific thing.
What would that be like?
FOMC, a rate announcement, something to that effect, and the market will reprice aggressively
quickly to a price that's well outside the scope that would be reasonably expected for
that short term perspective.
Big explosive price movement.
The economic calendar is useful in that respect because you can go in and see where these
events are likely to form.
So I'm looking for days in my son's model where he can go in and engage price when there
is a medium or high impact news event.
Or if there is a lack of one, he can practice but he shouldn't be engaging with his normal
risk percentage.
First element is time.
So at 8.30 in the morning, that's when a news embargo lists.
That's the first element of time that I taught you with this model.
The second one is 9.30.
That's right here.
The first here.
At midnight New York local time, that opening price is here.
Did the market rally above that opening price at 8.30?
Yes.
Are we bearish?
I proved this morning I was expecting lower prices.
I preferred lower prices.
So that means we're above the opening price at midnight.
So my power three concept is you want to be shorting at or above the opening price at
midnight in New York local time.
If you're trying to capture movement on a daily range on a down day.
So that opening price, look what happens.
We run up, take out short term highs here.
That's a short term run on liquidity.
Who's going to have stops at that one minute?
Anybody that would have put a stop loss in on these lower timeframes.
There's traders that are doing that all the time.
The algorithm is not aware of how much volume rests above or below a high or low that's
penetrated.
It has no understanding of that.
It doesn't need it.
For folks that are perplexed by that statement, and I've said it several times in the past,
you ever play a video game?
How about Pac-Man?
I'm a child of the 70s.
I was born 1972, August 8th, 7-Eleven p.m.
See that 7-Eleven, lucky 7-Eleven.
I came in the world with some luck, didn't I?
So when you're looking at a game like Pac-Man, okay, what keeps Pac-Man inside the boundaries
of those lines that make up the maze that it runs around and collects and eats those
dots until it gets to a power dot or chased down and killed by the ghosts.
The program language keeps him limited.
The play board or game maze has limitations.
Those limitations are programmed as such.
Every video game today, they have a map, okay, Fortnite, Call of Duty, Battlefield, all that
genre of video game creation, all those maps or territories that the player gets to enjoy
and explore, they have limitations, okay?
The daily range has those limitations programmed into it as well until manual intervention
is brought in and those initial boundaries are removed.
Okay, so think of a price like that.
So if you know that we're likely to see that in terms of like an analogy, we're at 8.30,
we're above the opening price at midnight, we ran a short-term high here.
The algorithm doesn't care how many orders were above that, it doesn't care.
It just has to take out a short-term high, it does.
So it's at a premium, it took out buy side.
So what is it likely to do now because we're in a bearish day and we're above the opening
price and it's at 8.30?
Reprice for what?
Where's sell side?
This level down here, 4101 or what, 4100 big figure, 4100 level.
So there's liquidity resting below that.
What kind of liquidity?
If market price is here and sell side is here, it's old lows, there's sell side below that.
So market price is here, relative equal lows in the past is this level here.
Go back in the beginning of the video, okay, you won't understand what that level is then.
That liquidity is sell side.
We're at a premium here, this would be a discount because market price is here or here, anything
below it is what, discount.
So the algorithm goes from buy side liquidity at 8.30 on a bearish day above the opening
price, wait for the market to trade lower, it does, short term low, see that, swing low,
trades through it, creates a fair value gap, rally back up to it, sell short with the expectation
it's going to run to sell side liquidity.
This is what I'm teaching my son to do at 8.30, that's all he's trying to capture there.
In this move, he may not run all the way to the sell side.
He's going to get his five points, once he does, he's stopping.
He gets out and then he watches the move go to the sell side of the liquidity pool.
Why am I telling him to get out five points?
Number one, five points is very, very easy.
I think that that is the lowest threshold of points a setup should hopefully yield.
If you're trying to do anything less than that, you're doing ultra short term scalping
and the commission costs will kill you, it ain't worth doing.
I think five points is an easy threshold.
You can do it once in the morning, you can do it once in the afternoon, even on a really
weird, choppy day, you could reasonably pull out five points if you have the experience.
You don't have that experience yet, so let me put that in your mind right now because
I don't want you thinking, well, I'm going to go out there tomorrow and do what ICD said.
I've only been trading for a week, so I think he's really convinced me that I can pull this
off and it's going to be 10 points a day for me, five in the morning, five in the afternoon.
This is going to be cakewalk.
I'm not supposed to put in my two weeks in this now and tell the boss, pound sand.
No, no, no, no, don't do that.
You're not ready, but if that's a goal for you, start working towards it.
Over time, my expectation is that my son will have a better understanding of what he's doing
and those five points, he'll have hopefully learned to take a portion off at five points
and then hold for that liquidity pool to be hit, and because of doing that very thing,
he's rewarding himself initially while he's learning, so it engages him.
It shows that he can make more money doing this than his job.
That does not mean that you can do more than your job.
I'm saying this is my son, he has me as his father, I'm sitting with him, I'm coaching
him, I'm telling him what he should be focusing on, I'm questioning why he isn't focusing
on other things, so I'm actually co-piloting him, I'm giving him visual and audible clues
as to what he should be using to navigate price.
Don't think for a moment, folks, that he sat down and did a couple days of talks with daddy
and now he's out there making 400% gains from his equity level up to where it is now.
That is not what took place.
He has the benefit of me sitting with him, talking to him, much in the same vein that
I did with you all this morning on Twitter, where I said, this is what I'm looking at,
these are the levels I'm looking for, if this breaks, I think we're going down to that level,
I'm doing that on a minute-by-minute basis with Caleb.
He's literally driving a car with me talking about every pothole, every potential hazard
that's coming, I'm reading the mind of all the drivers around us and telling him what
they're going to do before they do it, so it's a totally immersive experience for him.
Admittedly, it's a little intimidating for him, it's too much at some times and we have to repeat
certain things or he gets confused or he's apprehensive or reluctant to do something
or he second guesses something, all those types of things that any human being would have
with dad's expectation to learn how to do this and also you're dealing with real money.
I'm teaching him to respect what to do and when it's wrong, he feels it.
It's not a matter of, well, you know, I can reset a demo account, no, this is real money.
So when he sees the money going up in his account, he feels that good feeling.
If he has entered a trade and it's drawing down on him, he's feeling that.
Now, I know what I'm looking at, I know what I'm expecting, he doesn't, so I'm allowing him to
experience those things, but five points I think is a reasonable low threshold.
Over time, he will by default learn to trade with more than five points, but I got to give him
something to hit that it's easy, that low hanging fruit approach, that's how I teach, just like I
taught on baby pips when I first came out, 25 pips a week, you should be aiming for that and when you
get it, stop. Does that mean when you're trading 10 years from now, that's all you're going to do?
No. People that have been highly critical of me, they like to take the things I say, I like to
make a straw man argument about it and they have no idea what I'm doing with the new student, I'm
targeting an audience that is trying to do something that's going to give them encouragement,
feel like they're progressing and don't think for a moment that five points just once a day isn't
good because you could literally do very, very well. Think about it this way, if you just did
five points in the EMA SMP1 contract, you're not going to be able to do that, you're not going to
in the EMA SMP1 contract and never engaged money management to the degree where you start
parlaying it up and start doing two contracts and then two contracts becomes four contracts
eventually and then eventually you're trading E. If you just did one contract, okay, calm down
for a second and just listen to me for a moment, if you just did one contract of the mini SMP,
that means one point in your favor or against you is worth $50. Now $50 times five,
that's $250 a day. If you did that consistently once every single day, that's 25 handles or points
a week. That's $1,250 a week. I'm quite certain after polling my audience
on Twitter, which isn't my entire audience obviously, I have a lot of people, there's a
lot of people that actually leave comments on my video on YouTube that I can see that they're a
subscriber and I can also see the comments that are left by subscribers. Usually I answer the
questions that people present to me if they're a subscriber because it's kind of like a little perk
because I have like a goal. I want a million subscribers. I ain't gonna lie to you. I want
to have a million subscribers on this channel and I'm surprised and really honored and humbled that
so many of you subscribe to this channel. I mean 260 some viewers, I thought by the end of the year
I could have had 250,000 but now I'm almost on my way to 300,000 before I know it. This channel
could be in a year or two at my goal of a million subscribers. But folks that follow me and they
leave comments, if it's a comment that I want to address, I usually will respond to those that have
that little mark next to their name. You can't really see it but I can because it's the channel,
I'm the owner of the channel. So I can see who's commenting with a follow and if you follow me,
I appreciate that. Thank you for that but I don't want any of you to
think that you're going to make five points every single day. For instance, I took a loss of five
points yesterday. I could have easily went back in and made four times that later in the afternoon
but that's just me. You don't have that skill set and confidence yet that okay if you take a loss
and you took five points as a drawdown, you're going to want to go back in and do it right away.
Whereas I can and I chose not to because I want you to feel like okay it's okay and I even proved
that I can call a move even in the afternoon. I said this is where it's going to go. I pointed
to a specific level and went to it. I said that we would run out the lows and then we would break
a trend line that retail thinks is you know noteworthy and they destroyed it. Go back and
look at the comments on Twitter. I don't delete a single tweet. Zero. So I'm laying breadcrumbs down
for you but I'm not going to spoon feed you. You're going to earn it here and that makes some of you
angry. It frustrates some of you and no amount of frustrated replies to me or you know pointed
statements are going to make me change the way I do it because once you earn this skill set you
will not regret what you went through to get it and you will treasure it. You'll appreciate it.
It's not like reading a book that teaches you a magic trick and then you want to go around telling
everybody how to do the magic trick versus getting good at doing the magic trick.
There's a difference there. Okay so what I teach my son to do is at 8 30 he looks for a setup like
this. If it's a bearish scenario he's looking for liquidity below the marketplace and he's looking
for some type of framework where it gives a fair value gap. That is his pattern. That's what he
settled in on and we're going to run to liquidity and if it gives him five points he's out. Even
if the framework allows for 30 points he's getting out at five. Now I already know some
of you hotshots that's been doing it for a while or like to be critical or troll me
you just run your mouth. Oh this guy he's telling his son it could move 30 points but he's getting
out at five points. Who does that? Someone that's never traded live money before. That's who's doing
it. Okay someone that's already made 400 and some percent in one month that's who's doing it.
Okay someone that hasn't had a losing day in weeks that's who's doing it. So sit down take notes or
move along. In the afternoon there's a setup as well we'll get into that in a moment but the next
area of opportunity is the 930 hour. Okay so equities open at 930 and this is one I outlined.
The market was down here I mentioned on Twitter I said okay they opened it up at 930.
Initially started sending it lower and we'll talk about that in a couple minutes and what that was
and what information can be gleaned from that but I said that they're going to take price up into
the fair value gap and also clear 4105. It's all time and date stamped folks you can go back on
Twitter take a look at it's there it's undeniable it's not ambiguous it's very specific look at
the time on your chart it's here. I'm saying at 4105 that's where the buy side liquidity is that's
where the stops are and it's a fair value gap there it's going to reprice there and then you're
going to see the move the real move for the day. Market drops from there I went short on a demo
account and as price went below this low I tweeted first go back and look at the little recording
okay I'm not in here because there's people already going around in other forums and other
social media saying I'm trying to pump and dump because they now have a big audience they think
I'm going to go out there and say something hopefully create some kind of movement in the
marketplace and then I'm going to get out before I say I'm getting out no I literally record myself
saying pay the trader and then I go in and I take my partial as it goes below here go and watch the
video so I'm not doing any of those types of things folks okay I'm going to be your best friend
I'm going to be the best friend you could ever have in these markets if you just simply relax
and trust me I'm here to help you I'm not here to ask anything of you except for subscribe you know
that's like a trophy for me if I can get a million subscribers I want to have that I'll put the work
in to earn it but I'm not asking you to pay for anything I'm not asking you to worship me and
cheer my name and all that stuff none of that I just want you to have fun hang out with me
that's it because I promise if you do if you put the work into this stuff and hang out every single
day show up every single day even you don't understand it if you feel like you got confused
about what it is I'm doing keep showing up every single day that discipline will yield results
each one of you are going to have a different timeline is when you're going to get it I don't
have a deadline I don't have a I'm stopping when it gets this date I'm here now okay I'm enjoying
myself I'm having fun and hopefully you guys are having fun too but this setup here eventually
came back and ran back above the short-term high and ran here so we went one more time where above
the New York Midnight opening price so we're at a premium and above the opening price at midnight
and it consolidates in here and then it breaks down and later on in the afternoon we'll see
what it does now if you watch the video you can see that I actually entered in here went short I
was aiming for this I had a objective of taking two contracts off here so it went below that I
tweeted take partials or pay the trader first then I went into my demo account and closed out the
two as it went below that low so I was managing your expectations I was showing you what to do
with your demo account if you were doing anything and engaging and then I did my version of it
so I was given the instruction first and then when the market started going up I outlined this
order block here it started to repel away from that I actually mentioned I wanted to see price
stay below this level here all I did was extend this and then mentioned that over taken order
block here it was problematic I had anticipated if you watch on there in that short-term video
I had pulled up the partial close of three more contracts and my stop I hadn't moved
except for moving the break even a little bit better than break even after I took the partial
here and then once it went above this order block here that's when I closed three more contracts
before the stop loss was hit now I could have closed the entire order but to me that would
feel like panic okay I don't mind the stop loss getting hit because that's teaching you that's
what they're paid to do you're paying a stop loss to do its job I'm not worrying about price going
higher than my stop loss but if I have an ability to take something off before the stop is going to
go there and maybe maybe it goes close to the stop loss and it doesn't hit it I've taken something
off which was that initial partial here plus three more contracts and I had a remaining three
contracts that got stopped out better than even so I didn't scratch on any position I didn't take
in my opinion large enough position off down here in retrospect but that's how it's going to be for
you now the question is going to be this why did I pick this candle why was I concerned about it
when it went above it and why did I close the three contracts when it went above that how did
I know it was reversing basically what you're asking now if you look at this sell side liquidity
pool we have outlined here that was explained on twitter it's also been shown on this video here
at the beginning of the video so if you look at the liquidity up here the old lows we went below
that so sell sides been tapped here then it went lower and created a relative equal lows here
creating what another level of sell side below that it went below that so we now have another low
formed here what's resting below that sell side people are always trying to buy lows they're
trying to pick bottoms so the sell side gets taken once more here and then this low gets taken here
so notice what's occurring we went below sell side here here here here here here and here
without moving very much
notice that so after we've taken buy side liquidity here it should have been off to the races and went
lower and this should have capped price on the upside because it's an up close candle
institutional workflow my rules for teaching that to you is if we're bearish and workflow is bearish
this should have stopped price like it did here it should have maybe touched it one more time here or
just bumped above that short-term high and then went aggressively lower it did not do that that's
why if you watch the video of me actually doing the trade i actually pull up the order to take
three off because i'm watching to see if this is going to fail because it didn't tear off and take
that low out because it was reaching back up in its order block and then started going into it
i knew i was going to get smoked on the stop so it would be easier for me to just take partial
three off which i had pulled up on my chart ready to go versus just clicking to close the entire
trade which in my opinion wouldn't be as instructional for you because i want to show you how you can
still many times take something off again and it might not hit your stop loss and then it resumes
going your favorite and hopefully you can add those three contracts or whatever the portion would have
been if you had taken the trade put them back on and add it you know as a pyramid type thing
but because we took this up close candle out that was problematic because we had multiple levels of
sell side taken below the original sell side liquidity that was outlined the beginning of
the day on twitter so in short what should have happened was we ran the buy side here that should
have been the high of the day and then it broke lower but because it took out this candle here
after taking multiple levels of sell side what's the algorithm going to do
seek buy side where is it now above this high here so it's doing that run up here and then back
above midnight opening candle price at opening new york local time at midnight
and in the afternoon if my son has taken a trade in the morning and was profitable he'll do another
trade in the afternoon he's aiming for either 8 30 or 9 30 for his morning session move
if he gets his five points at 8 30 he won't trade at 9 30 if he misses something at 8 30 he'll try
at 9 30 either or he's trying to do one time in the morning now he can take a loss at 8 30 then
he can try to make it back with the 9 30 setup if he misses the 9 30 setup or takes a loss in the
morning he can trade the afternoon if he makes money in the morning i tell him paper trade or
demo trade the afternoon okay why why not push your edge if you have an edge ict if your son's
so good and he's doing what he's being taught to do why shouldn't he be trading every session move
because i'm not teaching him to be greedy i'm teaching him discipline because if he can see
that he can make more and chooses not to do it there's a certain measure of confidence
assurity
contentment knowing that you can go into these markets anytime and get it in that
fact that understanding that realization is a peace of mind that keeps me from going in
and over trading it keeps me from going in and doing more than is necessary and it never
allows me to fear and keeps me from ever fearing that these things are going to stop working
like i understand that i get lots of new students and they see what i'm doing and
they're afraid that all these people that are following me are somehow going to break the
market because they're all doing the same thing no because you're going to find setups that are
going to be different than i'm entering and i can do a lot other things that aren't even in charts
so i'm not worried about these things failing because i taught more people to do it because
if you look at the folks on my twitter feed that are just subscribing to me and they're looking at
everything i say and they think that's a code word for take a buy or take a sell and that's they're
rushing in to take a trade they need to be slowing down there's always going to be people out there
just because they're being exposed to this content they're not going to be disciplined
enough and there's going to be people that come to this youtube channel
and they are watching these videos and they're studying the concepts and they're never going
to make it work for themselves not because they don't work but because they're doing things with
them in an undisciplined manner they're doing things willy-nilly they're trying to you know
recreate the wheel because they want to be able to say they did something they made something they
created it it's their authorship it's their concept it's their thing their model their
approach to what they learned from me because it's clout they want clout clout is the thing
everybody wants right now clicking the buttons watch my videos come to my channel you know that
type of thing attention to me and those types of people aren't going to be the successful ones the
ones that don't care about being looked at or cared to be followed they're going to be probably
the best out of the entire fold here because that's how it is in my private group the ones
that are the most quiet they're the ones that are doing it the best they're not trying to make a
image on themselves they only care about the results and their results are significant
enough for them not to look for outward you know approval but in the afternoon what was the time
I taught you in this mentorship when is the afternoon session for pm session trading in
index futures after lunch but specifically what time 130 so at 130 right here we're leaving an
area of buy stops that have been taken it's breaking down then the market returns back to
a bearish breaker there then it starts to go lower we have displacement here
that could have been an entry there once more low taken here and now we have where I'll have
equal lows they are broken there see that this is what I'm training my son to see this is a valid
setup but I'm looking for these types of things for him because look what this is this low this
low and this low what's resting below that sell side liquidity on a bearish day so does it want
so does it want to drive down into that it does does it create an imbalance there it does does
it trade back up into it yes that's where he's going to be selling short and he's looking for
his five points and then he's watching and studying does it go to that 40 70 level that I was talking
about does it go down to that daily fair value gap that I was talking about before the market
opened this morning and those things will deposit pseudo experience that over time
results into real experience and then he can lean on those instances of experience where he's been
here before he's not intimidated if he's done it wrong he's not fearful that the market's
changing the way it does things because he's now suddenly profitable and it has a you know series
of losing trades or whatever he's not losing his mind because he has taken a trade that he felt was
lined with likelihood and probabilities in his favor but then failed he's not discouraged by that
because he knows that these things repeat so best case scenario there's three opportunities for him
a day he's looking for just one of them to yield five points if he does he makes more than half
of his weekly salary on that one trade he's trying to do that once in the morning once in the
afternoon he's taking a live trade in one or the other but once he gets one live trade he's trying
to condition himself to do demo or he'll paper trade it whatever just watch and observe but he's
not trying to do three trades a day initially i forced him into doing that i said take a trade in
the morning take a trade in 8 30 take a trade at 9 30 take a trade at the afternoon and then take
and also sometimes at three o'clock to four o'clock that market unclosed macro that runs by the
op rhythm there's a little setup that forms most days of the week in that last hour it looks similar
to this it might be a buy day it might be a buy setup not just a short setup but i'm taking it
into specific times of the day time i'm taking him to the market at these times okay if you have not
been paying attention this video i've literally laid in your lap the very moments that these
setups are forming it's up to you to go through your charts and find out if that is true the lazy
won't do it they want to be told what to do they don't want to go in and roll their sleeves up and
find it but once you see this once you see it and you back test and you pull out with example after
example after example of how the market sets up like this and it runs the liquidity above or below
the marketplace count how many times over the last month three weeks two weeks one week
how many setups offered five points with something just like this at these key times of the day
and then do the math if you could just do one half of that
or just one quarter of that with one mini
it's real easy to see how it's just a matter of time
before that thing you call a job no longer is a hindrance to you because it is a hindrance to you
where you have your faith chained to their bosses generosity they're so generous that they make you
work those 40 hours sometimes more to get that paycheck that uncle sam gets the tax before you
touch it and you come out and find out that everything's much more expensive today
when you have this skill set folks i want you to understand what i'm about to say and i'm going
to close this video when you learn this skill set
it removes fear it removes fear of missing out it removes the fear and anxiety of
failing but it also removes the fear of inflation because this skill set
will always outpace inflation i don't care if gas is 20 dollars a gallon i'm sure i'm going to
drive my corvettes i have eight cylinder corvettes that i absolutely will not leave parked i will
drive them and i will enjoy them i don't care gas can be whatever it wants to be it's a write-off
for me okay i don't care how much food is going to cost i hope i i can continuously find it
but i'm not worried about what my utility bills are going to cost i don't worry about what things
are going to cost that skill set that you're learning here it aids in that it helps in that
notice i'm not promising you get rich notice i haven't said that because i don't want you
coming to my channel thinking i'm promising you to get rich
but i am promising you a skill set that offers the opportunity to do limitless limitless feats
and wonders and it's only limited by your imagination how much work you're going to put
into it how much work have you put into it who are you allowing to influence you and discourage you
and discourage you distract you are you seeing results am i proving this stuff works
do you feel scammed or do you feel energized and thankful that you're part of a community like we
have here that's thriving it's energetic they're happy they're uplifted they encourage one another
and everyone here knows that they're not being taken for a ride
there's no upsell coming doesn't that feel good it frees you up to just concentrate on learning
there's no angle there's no sales pitch coming isn't that awesome isn't that cool that's like
the point is is you're you're in a community that we're all trying to help one another
and all i'm trying to be is the captain of the team and just lead you in the right direction
and hopefully avoid the pain and struggles that i went through
real accounts real money real buttons are being pushed
you are going to find
that there is a lot of opportunity that you're going to let slip by and not be upset about it
it's going to be one of the most fun experience that you're going to have
as a developing and developed student of price action under me is you'll see so many
stuff you're like i could do this trigger now but i'm not going to and then walk away from it after
it comes to fruition thinking i could have done that and i had the discipline to say no
because i'm not being influenced by fear or greed
and when you're at that level and you're consistent you have graduated you are an
independent thinker you have mastered fear and greed you have operated with a level of
discipline that is unknown to majority of traders on youtube instagram facebook wherever
that day is coming for you but you got to go through this stuff here to get to it it's not
hiding from you i'm not making it hard for you i've literally taught you everything except for
money management which we'll talk about next week and then you have the complete understanding of
what it is you're doing here and you're just going to do the same thing every day sometimes
you'll get it right some days you won't when you get it wrong you stop you don't rush to get it back
you don't rush to get it back and you're gonna find the next day sometimes there it is
which you took as a loss the previous day comes back sometimes with interest
and that's a good feeling when it happens it's like well you know i don't need to worry about it
you know losing trades is like getting a flat tire it sucks it costs you a little bit of money
and time delays you from what you're trying to get to accomplish but it's just a speed bump
cost a little bit of time and money but it didn't keep you from getting where you're going
it just created a detour a delay but the inevitable happens still nonetheless you arrive
at your destination your destination here is excellence and you don't get there overnight
you get there gradually one step in front of the other a little bit here a little bit there
sometimes you have to take a step or two back get your footing again and resume going forward
and sometimes you'll have to take a detour once in a while
that's all part of it that's the that's the growth that every trader goes through
but when it gets hard for you when you feel like you want to quit that's a moment when you need to
take a break take a week off don't watch my videos they'll be here i'm not taking my videos down
take a week away from it enjoy another hobby and then come back to it fresh
you want this to be enjoyable you do not want to make it
i have to do this it must work i got to get out of my job right now
because it's just going to make it harder and longer for you to learn it
have fun with it enjoy it i have to ask a question here and then obviously by the
way i've got a number of comments in either support of it or there's no interest in it
whatever but if you'd be so kind to let me know in the comment section if you would like to see me
do a very short i'm talking like two minute three minute review each day where the setups were for
the s&p and or nasdaq i'm not going to do both of them because it takes too much time to do that
but where were their setups for you to engage with what i'm teaching you here in this mentorship
if you'd like to see that as a monday through friday short little upload just let me know in
the comment section below also if you could include also what your experience been so far
under my teachings on this youtube channel has it been a positive experience for you
has it been not so much of a impact on you or has it been just simply waffle
maybe i'm uh you know missing the mark entirely be honest with me but just be
respectful if it hasn't been your cup of tea you know you can respectfully tell me that and that's
okay i'll just use your feedback to hopefully try to dig in a little bit deeper and maybe i
can find something that helps you or maybe not i don't know but i'm looking for feedback and
that way you can help me in that regard in the comment section below and until i talk to you
next time lord willing on tuesday enjoy your weekend and be safe